[Applause]
[Music]
it's a new month which means new
releases is giving you a wide view of a
bunch of new games I can't promise I'll
stop saying the word new but I'm pretty
sure you'll find something in March to
get hyped about here are some of the
biggest games launching this month
Kirby all-star allies is all about
teaming up that means playing four
player co-op Shore but the game's new
heart mechanic means you can bring up to
three enemies on your side even when
playing alone and of course you can
always chow down on those bad guys and
use their special powers too you can hop
to it on Nintendo switch on Friday March
16th oh yeah I forgot to mention King
DDD's massive pecs
we've actually got a clip of that buff
boss fight you can check out right now
let's move from one exclusive to another
and see if thieves is all about teaming
up too if I tell you the game is all
about forming a pirate crew with your
friends you can probably figure out the
rest you can explore a massive ocean run
a tight ship battle other crews search
for buried treasure and so much more and
it all comes with that signature
silliness from developer rare after some
high seas delays you and your matey's
can finally band together on Xbox one
and PC on Tuesday March 20th now let's
talk about a way out which is yet
another game that's all about co-op
funny how that works out anyway one
player controls Leo the other controls
Vincent and you both just want to get
out of jail this forced co-op experience
means one of you can interact with the
environment when the other is in a
cutscene or face a sticky situation from
multiple angles you can find your own
way out on ps4 Xbox one and PC on Friday
March 23rd and if the game is anything
like its director you'll be in for some
surprises along the way
another game looking to surprise you is
ninokuni to revenant kingdom this RPG
sequel puts you in the shoes of Prince
Evan looking to reclaim his stolen
throne hundreds of years after the first
game if you played the original you
might not be expecting the game's new
Pikmin like sidekicks the higgledy s
which you can command in combat and
you'll definitely be getting into lots
of battles across the game's open-world
after its second delay ninokuni 2 is
locked in for ps4 and PC on Friday March
23rd our last game for this episode got
delayed too but far cry 5 is still
looking to make a bang this month the
series is known for some pretty exotic
settings but this time you're being
dropped right into the American Midwest
where a cult has overtaken an entire
county cue the usual gun field missions
full of commandeered vehicles and all
sorts of crazy firefights only this time
you're fighting to let people back into
their hometowns not just taking down
enemy encampments you can load up on ps4
Xbox one and PC on Tuesday March 27 and
those are some of the hottest games
we'll be playing all month long as
always remember that release dates are
based on retailer listings and are
subject to change thanks for watching
guys and I'll be back with a more
focused weekly episode of new releases
next Sunday